[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
Село може бути нормальним, може бути супер,
тобто ти можеш жити в ньому і щось творити.
[Закарпаття, с. Нижнє Селище
Селиська Сироварня]
А це важливо, бо українець, він...
На жаль, найбільша наша проблема:
ми не віримо самі в себе.
[Петро Пригара
Сировар]
Ми думаємо, що хтось нам має щось зробити,
щось допомогти.
Ну, хоча з людьми...
Люди за ці два роки стали озлобленіші.
Це пов'язано з економічними показниками.
Коли до мене на сироварню багато молока
приносять, це є показником того, що держава...
Ну, соціальний рівень людей слабкий:
вони рахують кожну копійку,
кожен літр молока стараються
принести на сироварню, а не вилити,
чи лишити десь вдома,
чи вилити просто свиням...
Виробництво, переробка молока
потребує дуже багато миття,
тобто робота: бідони, форми, кришки, гирьки —
це все треба мити… Сепаратор.
Фактично, тепер дівчата митимуть форми,
з яких вчора сир забрали.
Молоко приїхало з села Нанково –
варитимемо другий котел.
Перший котел уже вариться,
відбувається пастеризація — зараз побачимо.
Частину молока я пропускаю через сепаратор,
забираю вершки,
тобто процентів десять молока я перепускаю
для кожного котла через сепаратор.
Перше моє стажування було влітку 1995 року
в Альпах, біля міста Грюєр.
У полонині, 1400 метрів над рівнем моря.
Там було 44 корови.
Ми пасли, доїли, ну і варили сир на дровах.
Там електрики не було,
був генератор для доїння.
[Варили сир] у мідному котлі.
Це було перше таке моє навчання серйозне.
Там пробули півтора місяця.
Найважче, що там було, – власник,
бо він характер мав досить жорсткий,
і він з нами працював.
Швейцарець такий, справжній швейцарець.
Друге те, що, як власник будь-якої ферми,
він знав усі 44 корови по імені.
На кожній була бірочка з іменем,
але він їх усіх впізнавав вже за метрів 30-40,
знав кожну, як звати.
Їх треба було прив'язувати кожну на своє місце,
не дай Бог було сплутати.
Коли я питав, чому мене запросили,
то господиня, наприклад, мені пояснювала,
що її батьки ще досі бояться,
що росіяни прийдуть і постукають у двері,
а нас вважали за росіян.
[Бояться], що прийдуть і
постукають у двері солдати.
Я питав, чи вони не боялися українців приймати,
все-таки пострадянська держава...
Чи вони розуміють, що таке Україна,
чи це радянський союз для них, чи що...
Якщо ти береш людину, ти дивишся, звідки вона.
Як мінімум, отримуєш якусь інформацію.
якщо береш [людину] з такої країни,
як Україна, з пострадянської держави...
Ну бо інколи нас вважають росіянами,
інколи приймають за інших,
але все одно, хоч і є багато негативу,
загалом я не мав ніколи
проблем через те, що я українець...
Ніде закордоном.
Це один із найважливіших моментів:
порізка найбільш скислого молока на сирне зерно.
Тут важливо не робити зайвих рухів,
рухатись впевнено, чітко,
бо від цього залежить, скільки сиру
ми зможемо зібрати із цього молока.
Тепер наше завдання —
його помішувати і нагрівати.
Я постійно мушу контролювати і акцентувати увагу
на самій якості продукції. Це те, що я і роблю.
Можливо, більше працювати з людьми,
з фермерами напряму —
важливо для покращення якості  молока.
А щодо проєктів? Ну, це туризм. Чому туризм?
Тому що, на мою думку,
на Закарпатті це єдиний сильний потенціал,
який може допомогти Закарпаттю економічно,
а українцям — допомогти відчути себе
вдома щасливими.
Тобто не їхати в Туреччину, Францію чи ще кудись.
А бути вдома, у себе, в Україні.
Я вважаю, це мало б підіймати нас:
коли в себе вдома можеш відпочивати,
можеш побачити щось цікаве, щось скуштувати.
Більшість чоловіків їздить на заробітки,
а жінки, окрім утримання сім'ї,
шукають якийсь підзаробіток тут.
В Україні немає такого поняття, як «сировар»,
бо це реально чоловіча робота.
А у нас все, що пов'язано з продуктами,
особливо на Закарпатті,
усі вважають жіночою роботою.
Ось така етажерка [полиця].
Це два сири, ще робимо третій — «Хуст».
Його всього двадцять хвилин
в сольовій ванні тримаємо.
Тут контролюємо температуру
і частку солі у воді.
Вода звичайна.
Оце «Селиський» [сир].
Сири ми назвали...
Назви взяли місцеві, хоча традиції
використали [європейські].
Використовувати традиції Європи було правильно,
бо в нас їх немає,
тих старих-старих традицій.
Всі назви місцеві.
Тобто «Селиський» —
це від назви Нижнього Селища,
хоча філологи, особливо дуже затяті,
впевнені, що це не правильно.
Кажуть, що треба, щоб сир називався
«Селищанський», бо нижнє Се-ли-ще.
Але в селі люди говорять «Се-ли-ський»,
усі місцеві завжди так кажуть.
[Оператор
Дмитро Охрименко]
[Монтаж
Микола Носок]
[Музика
Jaroslaw Mugrauer feat Olenky-Oreliki Vzjaty]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]